>> Dana: SAN FRANCISCAN SAY NO
TAXATION UNTIL YOU FIX THE
HOMELESS SITUATION.
IF THE PANDEMIC HAD YOU
STRESSING, JOE ROGAN SAYS TEACH
THE DEMS THE LESSON.
THEY ARE THREATENING TO STOP
PAYING TAXES OF THE CITY DOESN'T
DO SOMETHING.
125 LOCAL BUSINESSES RECENTLY
WROTE A LETTER TO CITY OFFICIALS
SAYING THEY ARE FED UP, THAT IT
HURT THEIR BOTTOM LINE WAY TOO
MUCH.
WHICH IS WHAT GREG TOLD HIS
STAFF WHEN THEY ASKED FOR
AIR-CONDITIONING AND BATHROOM
BREAKS.
THEY ARE DONE PAYING TAXES
UNLESS THEIR DEMANDS ARE MET
INCLUDING 35 SHELTER BEDS,
MONTHLY DATA ON THE SERVICES
OFFERED TO THE HOMELESS AND A
PLAN FOR WHAT TO DO WITH PEOPLE
WHO DECLINED HELP.
SAID ONE LOCAL BUSINESS LEADER
"WHATEVER THEY'RE DOING, IT
ISN'T WORKING."
WHICH IS THE SAME THING, THE
AGENTS HAVE BEEN TELLING JIMMY.
>> A LOT OF TOUGH LOVE TODAY.
>> Dana: SPEAKING OF WHAT TO
DO AND THINGS AREN'T WORKING, ON
HIS PODCAST THIS WEEK JOE ROGAN
SAID THERE'S ONLY ONE WAY TO
HOLD OTHERS ACCOUNTABLE FOR
THEIR MISTAKES HANDLING THE
PANDEMIC.
>> I HOPE THERE'S LESSONS
LEARNED.
NO ONE WHO IS ALIVE TODAY HAD
EVER EXPERIENCED A TRUE
PANDEMIC.
I'M HOPING THAT NOW THAT THIS IS
OVER, PEOPLE ARE GOING TO
RECOGNIZE THAT SERIOUS ERRORS
WERE MADE AND NOT REPEAT THOSE.
THAT'S THE BEST YOU CAN GET OUT
OF IT.
>> WHAT DO YOU TELL THOSE
PEOPLE?
>> VOTE REPUBLICAN.
>> THAT'S WHAT A LOT OF THEM ARE
GOING TO DO ANYWAY.
>> Dana: HE'S PROBABLY RIGHT
ON THAT ONE ALTHOUGH NANCY
PANDEMIC DID SOME FINE WORK
DURING THE CHOLERA PANDEMIC.
LET'S CHECK IN WITH THE NEW
POLITICAL CORRESPONDENCE.
WHAT'S YOUR PREDICTION FOR THE
MIDTERMS?
LOOKING FORWARD TO THOSE GUYS
FILLING ON ON "THE FIVE."
JIMMY, MY SAN FRANCISCO STORY, A
SHORT WISE MAN NAMED GREG SAID
THIS IS WHAT HAPPENS WHEN YOU
GET ONE PARTY TOWNS.
WITHOUT LOYAL OPPOSITION, YOU
GET REVOLT.
>> THAT'S WHAT HAPPENED.
THEY WERE ROOTING FOR THEIR
PARTY INSTEAD OF THEIR QUALITY
OF LIFE.
NEW YORK AND SAN FRANCISCO ARE
THE WORLD'S TWO BIGGEST OUTDOOR
RESTROOMS.
THAT'S NOT A GOOD THING.
BUT WHY?
IT'S BEEN THERE FOR YEARS BUT
PEOPLE WANT THEIR PARTY TO GET A
WIN SO THEY DIDN'T ACTUALLY HOLD
ANYONE ACCOUNTABLE TO THE POINT
NOW WHERE IT'S ACTUALLY KIND OF
TOO LATE BECAUSE BUSINESSES
HOLDING OUT ISN'T GOING TO HELP.
IT'S JUST GOING TO PASS THE BILL
ONTO US WITH THOSE 87,000 NEW
IRS AGENTS.
THEY ARE NOT GOING TO PAY VERY
JIMMY FAILLA IS GOING TO GET
AUDITED.
>> Dana: IS THAT WHAT THEY
CALL IT FLUSHING MEADOWS?
JULIE, YOU SAID I LOVE
SAN FRANCISCO AND AGREE WITH THE
POLITICIANS IN CALIFORNIA.
CARE TO EXPLAIN?
>> I LOVE THIS IDEA.
I WANT A REBATE FOR EVERY
HOMELESS, STONED PERSON IN THE
CITY EXHALING THEIR SECONDHAND
SMOKE IN MY FACE.
I CAN SAVE A BUCK OR TWO.
THE POLITICIANS IN
SAN FRANCISCO.
THE HOMELESS SITUATION IN
SAN FRANCISCO, LOOK AT
LOS ANGELES.
LOOK AT EVERY DEMOCRATIC LED
CITY IN THIS ENTIRE COUNTRY.
IF YOU LOOK AT IF BY CRIME,
HOMELESSNESS, WE SHOULD BE
GETTING A DISCOUNT.
I WANT A DISCOUNT.
I DON'T MEAN THE FIVE FINGER
DISCOUNT I USED TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF WHEN I WAS 15.
SOME KIND OF REBATE.
>> Dana: CONFIDENCE WOULD BE
GOOD.
FROM A BUSINESS PERSPECTIVE, HOW
DOES THE SCOURGE OF HOMELESSNESS
AFFECT SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS AND
YOUR 125 BUSINESSES.
>> THESE POOR FOLKS.
I READ THEIR COMMENTS.
THEY ARE TAKING POO OFF OF THE
SIDEWALK IN FRONT OF THEIR
BUSINESSES.
THEY ARE MOVING THE HOME WAS
AWAY FROM THE DOORSTEP.
HERE'S WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN.
PEOPLE GET FRUSTRATED.
THEY CAN'T MAKE MONEY, THEY
DON'T LIKE THEIR LIVES.
THEY LEAVE.
THEY WILL LEAVE THE CASTRO
DISTRICT BECAUSE THEY CAN'T MAKE
MONEY THERE.
IT'S A SIMPLE THING.
AND THE CITY SHOULD DO
EVERYTHING THEY CAN TO SUPPORT
SMALL BUSINESSES, NOT STAND IN
THEIR WAY.
>> Dana: JOEY, WHAT SOLUTION
WOULD YOU SUGGEST?
>> THE REAL ESTATE MARKET AT
ALCATRAZ IS PROBABLY PRETTY BIG
RIGHT NOW.
YOU GET AN ISLAND ON YOUR OWN.
IT'S SPACIOUS.
AT THE END OF THE DAY, YOU GET
WHAT YOU ASK FOR.
YOU GET WHAT YOU VOTE FOR.
YOU GET WHAT YOU'VE ADVOCATED
FOR.
IF YOU DON'T LIKE IT, MIGHT BE
TIME TO DO SOME SOUL-SEARCHING
AND SAY MAYBE THIS WASN'T THE
WAY.
I'M A BIG EDGAR ALLAN POE FAN.
JIMMY.
WE ARE CALLING HIM LITTLE JIMMY
DICKENS.
SHORT STORY OR POEM.
THE PENDULUM SWINGS BOTH WAYS.
THE PENDULUM HAS BEEN PULLED SO
FAR LEFT IN PLACES LIKE
SAN FRANCISCO, IT'S GOING TO CUT
LOOSE.
IT'S GOING TO SWING BACK AND
PEOPLE ARE GOING TO PUSH BACK
AGAINST IT.
IT'S WHAT WILL BE LEFT OF THE
CITY BY THAT TIME HERE WILL BE
LEFT OF THE COUNTRY.
WE TALKED ON "THE FIVE"
YESTERDAY.
OR WE TALKED ABOUT ON YOUR SHOW
THIS MORNING, BE QUIET CRIME
CRISIS OF CITIES THAT AREN'T
NAMED SAN FRANCISCO,
LOS ANGELES, CHICAGO, NEW YORK.
THESE PROBLEMS ARE HAPPENING
EVERYWHERE.
SAN FRANCISCO FOR NOW IS TAKING
UP SPACE IN THE HEADLINES
BECAUSE HE USED TO BE A
BEAUTIFUL CITY.
NOW IT'S A BEAUTIFUL MESS.
>> Dana: DENVER IS ANOTHER ONE
I AM FAMILIAR WITH.
DO YOU THINK THAT ROGAN IS
RIGHT?
PEOPLE WILL THINK ABOUT NOT JUST
CRIME BUT WHAT HAPPENED IN THE
LAST FEW YEARS WITH THE
LOCKDOWNS.
THE FABLE WILL WANT TO VOTE
REPUBLICAN IN NOVEMBER?
>> I THINK A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE.
I DON'T THINK DEMOCRATS HAVE
READ THE ROOM ON HOW MUCH COVID
FRUSTRATION THERE IS.
PEOPLE ARE SICK OF IT.
THEY HATED THE HYPOCRISY.
SAN FRANCISCO IS ONE OF THE
EPICENTERS OF COVERT HYPOCRISY.
THERE MAY ARE THE MIRROR
I HAVEN'T BEEN TO BEIJING IN A
WHILE BUT I DON'T MEMBER THE
DISCO SCENE BEING VERY BIG OVER
THERE.
I DON'T APPRECIATE ALL THE CHEAP
SHOTS.
A LOT OF CHEAP SHOTS.
IF WE'RE GOING TO GET INTO A
DISSING CONTEST, YOU DON'T HAVE
A LEG TO STAND ON.
>> Dana: I DON'T KNOW IF
THAT'S ALLOWED.
>> I DIDN'T KNOW YOU HATED T